bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions qui vous donne les armes pour
résister à l'enfumage permanent
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du secteur touristique
bonjour où est elle bonjour olivier
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ces caches
quelles perspectives pour le secteur du
tourisme après la crise il est au coït
19 qu'elle est de déployer pour le
secteur comment les professionnels du
tourisme vive t-il cette crise ce sont
les questions à l'ordre du jour de ce
numéro de ses caches et pour y répondre
nous serons en deuxième partie avec avec
edgar vaudeville hôtelier dans la région
de beaune en bourgogne
mais d'abord olivier un point sur les
chiffres le tourisme est un secteur clé
dans l'union européenne
il représente à lui seul 10% du pib
européen et 27 millions d'emplois en
france le tourisme c'est 7 3% du pib et
2 millions de personnes concernées
alors qu'elle s'attendait à une
croissance de 4% l'organisation mondiale
du tourisme qui est rattachée à l'onu a
revu pour la deuxième fois ses
prévisions à la baisse fin mars l'om tu
es avait prédit une baisse de 20 à 30 %
des voyageurs internationaux cette fois
l'institution penche plutôt pour une
chute du trafic de 58 voire 70 8%
olivier a concrètement c'est
catastrophique pour le secteur oui une
chute de 78%
ça c'est catastrophique ne serait-ce que
58 d'ailleurs c'est aussi catastrophique
mais c'est là qu'on voit aussi le le
l'incompétence linglin préparation et il
eu le phénomène de deux dirigeants hors
sol
vous avez vu la déclaration de monsieur
macron qui le dimanche soir 10 à des
restaurateurs qui pourront ouvrir le
lundi
comment on peut penser à part avoir des
congélateurs pleins que des gens peuvent
commander le dimanche soir à à 10 heures
du soir face est ridicule tout ça c'est
c'est mal fait c'est mal préparée on a
des informations contradictoires on n'a
jamais quelque chose de
2 prévu de prévisible donc comment
voulez vous que les gens s'y retrouvent
ensuite il est certain que le ne va pas
y avoir une ruée dans les restaurants et
dans les hôtels
dès le jour où ça ou ça rouvre et
aujourd'hui avec les mesures qui ont été
prises d'éloignement des tables par
exemple dans les restaurants d'un maître
etc
ça va être compliqué ça va être
compliqué pour beaucoup de restaurants
qui n'ont pas forcément une terrasse
devant devant chez eux et qu'ils vont
avoir du mal à récupérer des clients
et puis qui vont avoir aussi du mal à
récupérer leurs salariés qui sont restés
chez eux pendant un bon bout de temps
payer 85 % de leur salaire donc qui
finalement trouve ça pas pas si mal que
ça pour une pour une partie donc ça
c'est du vécu ce que je vous dis c'est
par rapport aux discussions que j'ai
eues avec certains restaurateurs donc
cessé sur tous les plans ils savent
qu'ils vont perdre une partie de leur
chiffre d'affaires qu'en revanche leur
coup ils vont rester les mêmes et donc
beaucoup s'interrogent sur la suite des
événements alors c'est pas tout de suite
que ça va arriver c'est pas tout de
suite qu'on va avoir les effets complets
de ce qui s'est passé du confinement et
serra c'est c'est plutôt en septembre
c'est plutôt en octobre que les choses
vont être difficiles là pour l'instant
il ya les aides encore les aides et donc
les choses vont se compliquer à la
rentrée je pense et là on risque d'avoir
de mauvaises choses
alors justement olivier à vous évoquez à
lezennes en france pour tenter de sauver
les meubles
l'état a mis en place un plan des noms
fait le point avec le tiroir cache dans
toi de masse
face à la crise du coville 19
le gouvernement a dégainé les moyens xxl
pour essayer de sauver le tourisme c'est
bien normal
le secteur est de taille la france est
le pays où le plus visité au monde près
de 82 millions de touristes viennent
profiter de la tour eiffel de la côte
d'azur ou des alpes
chaque année en mai peu après le début
du déconfinement edouard philippe a donc
c'est donc un plan de 18 milliards
d'euros spécifique pour le tourisme un
plan très axé sur les entreprises les
plus fragiles type tpe pme ou un fonds
de solidarité qui est en fait une aide
jusqu'à 10000 euros pour ce type
d'entreprise est prolongé jusqu'à la fin
de l'année est étendue aux entreprises
ayant jusqu'à 20 salariés et 2 millions
de chiffre d'affaires
les fameux presse une garantie de l'état
ont été renforcées l'accès au chômage
partiel prolongé jusqu'à septembre
en plus d'encourager bien sûr les
français à passer leurs vacances sur le
territoire pour relancer l'économie
bref un bon paquet de mesures avec
toutefois des oubliés du secteur
les vacataires ou intermittent du
tourisme type hôtesses agents de
sécurité et cuisiniers qui ont
d'ailleurs manifesté à paris début juin
pour tenter d'attirer l'attention du
gouvernement sur cette malheureuse
négligence olivier ces mesures vont par
est elle suffisante non notoirement
insuffisantes pour la bonne et simple
raison que vous avez en effet un tas de
deux secteurs de personnes qui vont être
oubliée dans le dans la sphère que et
que je vous dis vous n'aurez pourrait
distribuer des aides c'est pas ça qui va
faire revenir les gens dans les
restaurants et pouvait les inciter en
les incitant à rester en france plutôt
que d'aller se balader mais ça n'empêche
que quand vous n'avez plus de souvenez
avait plus de sous donc il ya un moment
où il va bien falloir le prendre en
compte
on a eu des pertes énormes de de revenus
donc ces gens là ne vont pas aller dans
des dans des hôtels ou claquer de
l'argent dans des restaurants du jour au
lendemain parce qu'ils l'ont plus cet
argent donc faut bien se mettre ça dans
la tête par un mois sur les emplois
saisonniers ce sont les grands oubliés
de ce plan ça fait partie des oubliés de
ce plan mais peuvent enfin comprenez
bien systématiquement l'état recourt à
la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui ils distribuent de
l'argent qu'il n'a pas donc qui va aller
prendre quelque part
et cet argent qu'il va aller prendre
quelque part c'est justement chez les
consommateurs au niveau des impôts alors
monsieur macron peut dire ce qu'il veut
s'agiter dans tous les sens sur son
siège pour nous expliquer qu'il n'y aura
pas d'augmentation d'impôts bien sûr
qu'il y aura des augmentations d'impôts
bien sûr qu'il y aura une création
d'impôts parce qu'il va bien falloir
financer tout cet argent qui distribue à
tort et à travers
donc sachez que vous n'aurez vous allez
vous faire pomper votre argent par des
impôts donc revanchards et mattel
maquereau a pourtant précisé
il n'y aurait pas de nouveaux impôts
mais monsieur macron peut dire ce qu'il
veut toute façon il dit des bêtises
depuis le départ donc il dit des
mensonges depuis le départ donc ne
m'imaginais pas que cette fois ci ça
n'en est pas un l'argent il est pas y
tombe pas du ciel donc qui va bien il
prendre quelque part donc arrêtons avec
ces enfantillages où on a quelqu'un qui
nous dit tout et son contraire en même
temps puisque c'est ça fasse sa phrase
préférée
et bien je vous dis en même temps il y
aura pas d'augmentation d'impôts mais il
y aura d'autres mots d'autres impôts si
vous voulez qu'ils se comptaient comme
ça ils auront raison
on passe au sénat la deuxième partie de
cette émission et cette semaine pour
parler à des conséquences de la crise
liée aux covit 19 nous sommes en liaison
avec un hôtelier propriétaire du central
boutique hôtel à beaune égard aux deux
villes bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
bonjour lié moto alors comment est ce
que vous vous avez vécu la crise
racontez-nous olivier évoqué en première
partie une situation à catastrophe et
qu'est ce que c'est votre avis aussi
mais écoute je rejoins à 100% donc les
discours d'olivier donc du coup un flou
total
donc malgré les aides qui ont été
distribués donc goutte à goutte par
exemple tout ce qui était chômage
partiel ça a été remboursé qu'après deux
mois donc j'ai dû quand même de les
bercer presque deux mois de de chômage
partiel pour les différentes entreprises
restaurant comme hôtel le fonds de
solidarité
c'est pas avec 1500 euros qu'on va payer
les loyers et qu'on va payer toutes les
charges le report de cotisations pareil
c'est sont que des reports et
d'annulations les prés de garantie
pareil on va devoir aussi les rembourser
donc tout ça dans le même pot je vais
vous dire pour rejoindre
olivier c'est catastrophique et on a
besoin d'actions concrètes de l'état qui
pourrait être la baisse de la tva levée
donc les charges patronales est obligé
aussi les assureurs à à aider à
rembourser le manque à gagner
non messieurs venez donc on verra le
plan donne un peu dans les détails mais
aujourd'hui concrètement où on et vous
est-ce que vous avez ouvert alors on a
on a réouvert depuis presque un mois et
demi mais bon vu que les gens peuvent
pas circuler
donc on était à bout taghout depuis une
semaine on sent une petite augmentation
des réservations mais tout est dernière
minute donc on parle des réservations
qui sont sur les entre trois et six
jours maximum et donc non non ça prend
pas du tout juillet août reste reste nul
et sans compter fin septembre on va dire
la fin de la grosse saison on va avoir
une après saison mauvaise et on va dire
un début d'hiver
ça va être ça va être pas beau à voir
olivier que vous avez une question a
pour monsieur gilles oui lol je pense
que le le problème si vous vous laissez
vous dites baisse de la tva etc
c'est malheureusement le serpent qui se
mord la queue parce que l'état ne peut
pas baisser la tva parce que s'il baisse
la tva
il va falloir qu'ils vous le reprennent
de l'autre côté or on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que on est on
est tombé je voulais 10 x fois dans
d'autres émissions où se se cette crise
sanitaire arrive à un moment où il n'y a
plus de viande sur l'os on n'a pas
refait de gras on n'a pas refait de gras
en fait depuis la crise de de la
dernière crise et donc
malheureusement l'état aujourd'hui est
en ruine et on le voit surtout live
d'ailleurs surtout les les secteurs
l'état est en ruine il a besoin d'argent
donc s'il fait un cadeau ce qui serait
logique d'ailleurs ce qui lorsqu il
devrait pouvoir faire mais s'il fait un
cadeau comme la tva eh bien il le
reprendra d'une façon ou d'une autre de
l'autre côté donc de toute façon on est
on est dans une impasse
on est on est contre le mur et est
malheureusement il n'y a pas grand chose
à faire
comme en plus de ça il a mal géré les
choses
il a confiné tout le monde alors qu'on
aurait peut-être pu imaginer d'autres
scénarios
et bien aujourd'hui malheureusement je
vois pas très bien comment on peut se
sortir de là alors peut-être que vous
avez d'autres d'autres propositions mais
je vous dis les baisses d'impôts pour
moi c'est même le recours à la dette des
dettes garanties les dettes par
définition il faut les rembourser
et donc si vous n'avez pas d'activité
malheureusement ça va être compliqué de
de rembourser les dettes mais là on va
revenir justement se régler on l'a vu en
première partie à l'état a mis sur la
table une série de mesures pour aider le
secteur 18 milliards d'euros pour le
tourisme un plan daide qui se décompose
comme suit 9 milliards d'euros à
concernant les aides directes les aides
d'activité à partiel le fonds de
solidarité et les neuf autres milliards
concernant des programmes et
d'investissement vous monsieur ville en
tant que professionnels du secteur qu en
pensez vous concrètement de ce plan
olivier évoqué un gouvernement un
préparer en première partie est ce que
c'est aussi votre avis pour moi ils sont
préparés mais surtout il faut voir il
faut voir les choses parce que pour
l'instant on voit que ça parle beaucoup
mais il faut il faut du concret et pour
l'instant nous par les fonds de
solidarité
2500 euros et ses terrasses et des
pacotilles pareil
l'établissement on a des loyers jusqu'à
10000 euros comment on va faire pour les
payer vous voyez tout ça c'est c'est pas
que les mois où on est on est fermé
c'est surtout les mois après on va dire
parce que jusqu'à jeu qu'au printemps
prochain on va pas avoir la capacité le
chiffre d'affaires de plus de va dire 50
à 60 % au maximum de ce qu'on faisait
les années passent et donc le plus dur
c'est à venir et c'est là où sont
largement contrôlés et et on parlait de
charges patronales pour moi les charges
patronales ça va me permettre d'en vau
d'employer plus de personnes de
reprendre des salariés qui sont en
chômage partiel est donc d'offrir un
service supplémentaire à mes clients qui
pour le moment je dois faire vraiment
entre à gauche à droite utiliser l'un et
l'autre pour pouvoir combler les trous
parce que je ne peux pas me permettre de
reprendre des employés en chômage
partiel vous concrètement à combien
estimez vous votre perte et combien avez
vous reçu alors moi je vais vous dire
reçu en 1502 de fond de sonorités de
fonds de solidarité par don mensuel
on a reçu une aide régionale il me
semble de 5000 euros
et c'est tout donc les assureurs rien du
tout et la bataille on ne les estime à
combien ben moi les pertes pour
l'instant on va dire moi j'ai pas
réouvert les restaurants donc intervenir
juste seulement la partie hôtellerie
on va lui dire sur à l'année moi je
pense qu'on va être plus de façons 2%
alors pour revient qu'est-ce que quel
est concrètement un demande et vous
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait mettre en place
pour sauver le secteur bas dz moi moi je
pense dz bon déjà c'est bien d'avoir
quelques aides mais surtout ça va être
mon parlant de la tva et des charges
patronales
ça va être déjà des coûts en moins à
dépenser alors à l'heure d'ouverture et
moi c'est la reprise qui m'intéresse ce
qui est passée s'est passé les hôteliers
1 chambre qui n'est pas loué le soir
même elle est perdue c'est pas c'est pas
comme dans la restauration on peut lisez
une tu disais une denrée à peu après
donc il faut vraiment maximiser notre
marque notre marketing communication se
réinventer modifié et et en même temps
suivre les consignes les consignes qui
nous sont obligatoires olivier on va
travailler à écouter ci surtout d d d d
une mise en place de la de la gestion
sanitaire de cette crise là aujourd'hui
si on a faim on a on a quand même des
aberrations on laisse des gens se
sentent assez par exemple dans le métro
et il faudrait qu'ils aient un mètres
d'écart entre chaque personne dans un
restaurant enfin c'est aberrant soit on
ouvre réellement les choses et on dit
aux gens gobain fait attention mais on
trouve réellement les restants parce
qu'aujourd'hui le restaurant qui acquit
à paris par exemple n'a pas de terrasse
il fait comment il peut pas peut pas
rouvrir il peut pas ouvrir parce que
c'est ainsi les coûts qui restent les
mêmes
et de l'autre côté vous avez des droits
de tout un revers maintien où il faut
gérer les choses correctement
et puis ne pas dire je vous dis la
veille pour le lendemain le dimanche
tiens vous avez le droit d'ouvrir vous
avez le droit d'ouvrir demain seront vos
accès on voit que ccc ni fait ni à faire
qui discute avec les professionnels qui
voient un peu ce que ce qu'ils demandent
est ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut faire
parce que toujours vous d'y faire des
bébés baisse ponctuelle de
de tva ou permettre à ces boîtes la 200
dt alors qu'on sait pertinemment
qu'elles pourront pas rembourser
pertinemment parce que elles vont
rajouter de la dette à une dette
qu'elles ont déjà et et elles seront
incapables de rembourser parce qu'elles
n'ont pas de chiffre d'affaires à mettre
en face donc tout ça c'est franchement
c'est mal conçu c'est comme c'est comme
d'habitude c'est à dire on fait les
mêmes erreurs systématiques au lieu
d'aller discuter avec des vrais
professionnels et pas simplement avec le
directeur de cabinet qui sortent de
l'ena et qui a le jamais rien vécu et
jamais rien fait de sa vie
d'accord monsieur module une réaction à
sur cette phrase de jean baptiste
lemoyne secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères le tourisme a suivi et 30 à
40 milliards de pertes de recettes mais
la situation commence à s'améliorer
il ya eu un déclic psychologique et les
réservations sont montés en puissance
ces dernières semaines est ce que c'est
le cas est ce que vous avez à constater
une hausse des réservations est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça qu'est ce
qu'ils appellent pas aux de réservation
c'est avoir de réservations
supplémentaires par jour
oui dans ce cas là on peut appeler ça la
hotte de réservation mais non on n'est
pas du tout on est on est loin d'être à
à peine à 20 % d'occupation on va dire
sur les 30 % d'occupation sur sur les
dix prochains jours
mais si vous regardez sur jusqu'à fin
septembre
ça bouge pas encore moi je ne me sens
pas on sent pas encore un boost des
réservations après on pourrait voir avec
toutes les compagnies comme booking etc
et je les ai appelés il ya il ya une
semaine et il avait reçu une dizaine de
réservations seulement sur la région de
beaune donc donc sinon c'est très très
lent aussi j'avais aussi un point a à
relever donc encore une fois et tous et
airbnb eux qui mettent des prix cassés
jusqu'à 70% mais il ya des chambres ou
des appartements à 40 euros ou 50 euros
donc ça nous ça nous casse totalement la
reprise et ils n'ont pas de personnel
c'est c'est injuste et il faudrait qu'il
mettre en place des taxes sur tout ce
qui est locations touristiques et maître
des maîtres en place dès des choses pour
éviter que les hôteliers se passe trop
mangé par part à bienne be
monsieur vauzelle était 2020 sera en
était bleu blanc rouge c'est ce qu'a
aussi a déclaré monsieur le moigne dans
un entretien au jdd est ce que selon
vous hais les français vont suivre vont
ils privilégier les vacances en france
ou alors est ce que vous comptez sur un
retour d'une clientèle européenne avec
la réouverture des frontières mais
écoutez oui bon ils ont prévu lisez
leurs vacances en france mais les
français ils vont voyager chez les amis
chez la grand-mère louer des maisons à
plusieurs et il n'y a pas beaucoup de
français qui vont louer dès qu'ils vont
prendre des chambres d'hôtel et on voit
oui j'ai reçu quelques réservations de
dans différents établissements de
luxembourgeois suisses et belges donc le
moi je pense la clientèle belge
luxembourg aux landaises vont se
déplacer mais mais c'est tout on n'aura
pas de clientèle internationale
olivier en était un bleu blanc rouge
c'est ce qui permettrait de sauver le
secteur non mais non mais il vient de
vous le dit c'est ça va vous allez avoir
évidemment une petite reprise mais quant
au canton par 2 2 0 il ya quelques il ya
quelques semaines
alors évidemment on peut faire le
mariole en disant vas les les les
réservations ont augmenté de 100% de
100% bah oui elles ont augmenté de 200%
elles partent de zéro
c'est pas compliqué hein
mais vous avez le même phénomène partout
c'est juste c'est juste du marketing
vous avez eue hier ça n'a rien à voir
mais vous avez eu les les ventes au
détail qui ont été publiés aux états
unis
c'était le même phénomène c'est à dire
quand vous annoncez des hausses
spectaculaires mais mais la hausse
spectaculaire il fallait prendre en
compte que les ventes au détail elles
avaient baissé de 50% avant ou 60% donc
évidemment quand elle elle recommence un
tout petit peu ça vous donne des hausses
spectaculaires
enfin bon en attendant vous êtes
toujours 50 ou 60 % en dessous des
niveaux d'avant donc là c'est la même
chose on se on se vante d'un était
français ou vous allez avoir de
réservation et où on va vous dire mais
c'est quand même merveilleux ben non
c'est pas merveilleux tout ce qui a été
perdu et perdu définitivement et est
aujourd'hui je vous dis ça va être
compliqué de faire revenir les gens pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'on a tous
dans cette histoire perdu beaucoup de
revenus
donc il a pass da inventé tout seul donc
et quand vous allez dans une dans une
quand vous prenez une semaine dans un
hôtel
ça coûte de l'argent donc comme les gens
n'ont pas eh bien c'est pas parce que
vous allez avoir deux luxembourgeois et
deux suisses qui vont à qui vont arriver
chez vous que ça va sauver votre saison
merci olivier merci beaucoup et le gard
vaudeville d'être intervenu dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
hôtelier à beaune en bourgogne
non parce aux questions
je vous le savez olivier delamarche
répond désormais aux questions que vous
lui posez sur les réseaux sociaux ou en
commentaire des vidéos et on attaque
tout de suite avec la première question
sélectionnée et celle de janot pierre
n'est ce pas le moment de s'endetter
pour combler le déficit des retraites 30
milliards d'euros
étant donné que la dette de la france va
de toute façon explosé avec la facture
du coc vide 500 milliards d'euros
je trouve la chemise choses rigolotes
on va avoir une tête qui explose donc
n'est-il pas temps de s'endetter
curieux comme question je ne sais pas
quoi répondre
voilà tu voulais pas se veut vous
endetter pour combler un déficit le
déficit
l'isra il sera exactement le même
l'année suivante et l'année d'après et
c'est un déficit qui est chronique c'est
pas un déficit qui est conjoncturelle il
va en plus être être de pire en pire
puisqu'il ya un problème démographique
en europe et en france et donc je je je
je comprends pas bien la question c'est
encore un adepte de la dette qui
visiblement pense que on peut s'endetter
comme ça à l'infini donc en des temps
nous à l'infini c'est ce qu'on fait on
passe à la question à dos d'âne 888
olivier êtes vous favorable à des
mesures protectionnistes afin de
préserver nos emplois et nous protéger
de la concurrence déloyale mais je suis
toujours pour des mesures
protectionnistes intelligente le seul
problème c'est que je vous rappelle que
nous ne pouvons pas avoir des mesures
protectionnistes puisque nous sommes
nous faisons partie de l'union
européenne et que ça se décide au niveau
de l'europe et non pas de la france donc
d'abord récupérons notre souveraineté et
ensuite on pourra voir pour
réglez votre question et on termine avec
la question de dark master 75 bonjour
olivier est ce que décloisonner le code
du travail par exemple autoriser la
provoquer la prolongation des cdd au
delà de trois fois pourrait être une
solution qui pousserait les entreprises
à embaucher
non bien sûr que non pourquoi parce que
ça ça rendrait le travail encore plus
précaire qu'il ne l'est et
malheureusement je suis pas sûr du tout
que ça déclencherait des embauches
voilà donc c'est un mouvement qui est un
mouvement mondial avec la libéralisation
les les contrats à temps partiel on a vu
par exemple ce que ça a donné aux états
unis vous avez beaucoup de deux temps
plein qui sont transformés depuis 2008
en temps partiel et ça n'a pas et de
loin à améliorer les choses si vous
voulez donc vous avez des américains qui
sont retrouvés avec un deux trois
boulots pour essayer d'avoir un salaire
normal
vous aurez la même chose en france vous
aurez des gens qui auront un deux trois
boulots précaires qui leur donneront
droit à rien comme ce qui se passe aux
etats unis puisque à ce moment là vous
n'avez pas droit au chômage vous n'avez
pas droit à certains à certaines choses
medicare non plus etc et donc non c'est
pas le c'est pas forcément la solution
précarisés pour pour embaucher merci
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez
vous la semaine prochaine en attendant
vous pouvez évidemment reposer vos
questions à olivier sur les réseaux
sociaux et les répondra dans cette
émission n'oubliez pas non plus que nos
précédents numéros sont disponibles sur
notre site internet arte france point tv
et on referme cette émission avec vous
olivier bien écoutez je n'ai qu'un mot à
dire
foncez tous au restaurant peut-être que
ça va les aider